antenne de 20h le journal de la
rédaction
henri sannier bonsoir et bienvenue sur
le plateau d'antenne de à la une ce soir
la contre attaque du parti socialiste
dans la sphère lüscher
pierre mauroy est persuadé que
l'offensive vise directement le
président de la république
aujourd'hui le porte parole du premier
ministre a fait savoir que jacques
chirac n'avait pas l'intention
d'interpeller le président de la
république sur cette affaire
un jeune mélanésiens tué par un tir de
dissuasion des gendarmes de
représentants de l'or touché lors d'une
fusillade le regain de violence sur le
caillou pour le fln ks des incidents
inévitable après la requête de michel
roy tournant dans la sphère de la cncl
l'instruction du dossier suspendue
la cour de cassation dira le 10 décembre
si le juge grelier et des saisies ou non
du dossier françois léotard invité du
journal le budget de la communication
devant l'assemblée cet après-midi un
chiffre 8 milliards 700 millions
un débat la place de la création
française à la télé ne la quitte bercy
trahi par une déchirure abdominale le
français renonce à son quart de finale
contre xa peur yannick sera indisponible
plusieurs semaines
une journée supplémentaire de détention
pour marcel carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann jean
louis normandin d'antenne 2 et roger
auque les otages français au liban n'ont
toujours pas été libérés
la nouvelle calédonie une nouvelle fois
sous tension après la mort d'un jeune
mélanésiens de 18 ans le drame s'est
déroulé je vous le rappelle au cours
d'une opération judiciaire dans la tribu
de saint louis à 15 km au sud de nouméa
immédiatement un important dispositif de
sécurité a été mis en place et
apparemment apparemment le calme était
revenu à la tombée de la nuit
au-delà des faits on s'interroge une
nouvelle fois sur la fragilité de la
situation et on se demande surtout si un
fait divers tragique ne va pas déboucher
sur une nouvelle affaire politique
rachid arhab les incidents les plus
graves depuis les troubles de 84 en
nouvelle calédonie un jeune mélanésiens
tué au cours d'une opération de police
judiciaire
et c'est l'affrontement barrage jets de
pierre côté kanak grenades lacrymogènes
côté gendarmes
très vite ce sont les armes à feu qui
parlent une fusillade intense
si l'on en croit les témoins comme ce
journaliste de la télévision locale 1 2
puis plusieurs coups de feu claquent
si l escalade les gendarmes ripostent
spectacle de guerre un véritable
affrontement au fuji deux gendarmes
blessés l'après midi un jeune
mélanésiens tuées le matin
lourd bilan pour une simple enquête de
police depuis plusieurs jours les
gendarmes patrouillent et autour de
cette tribu à la recherche de quatre
suspects
et dans une banale affaire de vol de
bestiaux ce matin les forces de l'ordre
décident de perquisitionner dans la
tribu et doux bascule une femme est
apparue à ce moment-là 50 mètres de la
maison au bord de l'eau elle courait et
s'agiter au même moment les gendarmes de
tête des gens n'en parlent luthiste de
l'épi gn venue de koné pour cette
opération pour nous aider on détecte et
quatre jeunes garçons qui s'enfuyaient
en courant en direction de lahti ils
auront fait les sommations ont ouvert le
feu d'abord en l'air et ensuite auriol
jeunes dans leur direction sans
l'intention donc de les atteindre mais
de les faire cesser leur progression
pour les interpeller il n'y a pas eu de
sommation affirment les indépendantistes
à nouméa comme à paris les dirigeants du
fln qui parle ouvertement d'assassinât
trop c'est trop
et lorsque nous disons ça nous disons
que nous allons prendre toutes les
responsabilités qui incombent à la
gravité d'une telle situation et y
compris et y compris et compris le le
recours à l'auto défense pure et simple
sous les formes que cela recouvre en ce
moment les forces de l'ordre sont
stationnés non loin de la tribu saint
louis où l'on craint les réactions des
jeunes mélanésiens la sphère lüscher
encore et toujours à la une de
l'actualité les dirigeants socialistes
se déclare persuadé que pas un centime
provenant du trafic d'armes en iran n'a
fini dans les caisses du parti sur le
fond lionel jospin a quand même ajouté
hier c'est à charles hernu de démontrer
qu'il n'est pas concerné par cette
affaire
aujourd'hui c'est pierre mauroy qui a
frappé du poing sur la table depuis sa
mairie de lille dans le nord devant des
officiers de l'école des hautes études
de la défense nationale
pierre mauroy a pris la parole pour lui
aucun doute le président avait été
informé du trafic et il avait prévenu le
ministre de la défense
la confusion conclut un monde retenue
bon il écarte dans le but évident non
seulement de compromettre le parti
socialiste mais surtout d'atteindre le
prix stendhal l'existence des trafics au
profit de l'iran ont été signalés à la
fin du mois de mai 84 je peux simplement
dire qu'au milieu les dizaines de
messages qui sont quotidiennement passé
au président de la république et au
premier ministre
il me paraît tout à fait naturel
qu'informer d'un trafic
le chef de l'état a demandé que le miz
défendre soit saisi lui qui est le
supérieur hiérarchique
la dgse je ne vois pas quelle autre
réaction aurait pu être celle du
président du côté de la majorité c'est
denis beaudoin le porte parole de
jacques chirac qui a précisé une
nouvelle fois la position du
gouvernement aujourd'hui denis beaudoin
est formel matignon se refuse à toute
polémique politicienne et ne souhaite
pas interpellé le président de la
république sur cette affaire ce n'est
pas dans nos intentions de désigner et
ce n'est pas dans notre euro ni dans
notre esprit de désigner tel ou tel
boucs émissaires à l'opinion publique
dans cette affaire les socialistes
d'ailleurs ce serait bien de modérer les
roses attaque vis-à-vis de certains de
leurs propres chaînes
enfin il n'est pas question car il n'a
jamais été dans l'esprit de matignon
d'interpeller le président de la
république nous n'avons d'ailleurs
jamais employé de tels procédés
oui question naïve en lui le 16 mai
direct comment peut-on parler d' affaire
d'état sans égratigner entre guillemets
le président de la république bien je
vais vous dire c'est pas possible c'est
pas possible parce qu'au delà de sa
petite phrase sur l'anneau
l'interpellation du chef de l'état denis
beaudoin a bien pris soin de rappeler
deux fêtes
premièrement la sphère du cher s'inscrit
dans un contexte troubles un
détournement de fonds publics le
carrefour du développement une tentative
de subornation les irlandais de
vincennes et à un acte de piraterie
internationale avec mort d'homme le
rainbow warrior le fait de vouloir lier
son métier vraiment tout c'est tous ces
dossiers et déjà l'aveu implicite qu'on
vise bien le chef de l'état via l'ancien
gouvernement
on le parti socialiste ce qui revient au
même deuxièmement comme monsieur
beaudoin rappelle que le président de la
république était au courant d'un trafic
d'armes illicite avec l'iran le 21 mai
84 que le ministre de la défense de
l'époque charles hernu étaient informés
dès le 24 mai 84 mais que pour qu'il y
ait plainte
il fallait attendre le 13 mars 86 deux
ans plus tard et trois jours seulement
avant les élections législatives pour
que paul quilès le successeur de
monsieur r nul s'émeuvent de la chose
matignon a non seulement en ternes mais
qu il s il pense aussi à mitterrand on
ne veut peut-être pas nuire au président
on se contente de pouvoir souligner ses
40 alors interpellé ou pas françois
mitterrand va-t-il s'exprimer dans les
jours qui viennent on en parle
sérieusement l'un sur françois
mitterrand va répondre sinon dans les
jours qui viennent du moins dans la
semaine qui vient seulement le problème
du chef de l'état c'est de pouvoir
répliquer sans donner l'impression de
descendre de son piédestal l'arène de la
politique politicienne il connaît mais
ce n'est pas encore pour aujourd'hui
toujours est il que la sphère lüscher
doit être la dernière du genre avant
l'élection présidentielle
d'un côté comme de l'autre à l'elysée
comme à matignon on considère que c'est
le dernier envoi de pâques et bleu avant
le constat d'huissier économies un peu
moins d'agitation aujourd'hui mais le
dollar est toujours faible baisse à
tokyo paris et zurich est timide
redressement à francfort les
spécialistes sont formels le petit
billet vert continue à souffrir au
lendemain des déclarations du secrétaire
américain au trésor monsieur becker qui
avait déclaré crûment qu'il préférait la
baisse du dollar à la récession chez
nous on se demande maintenant si la
priorité est donnée à la défense du
franc ne va pas peser sur la croissance
nous y reviendrons côté bourse on note
une petite embellie aujourd'hui plus 0,9
à paris mais le moins que l'on puisse
dire c'est que le climat est toujours
aussi incertain
un climat qui pèse très lourd sur les
privatisations en général paris
maintient le cap avec quelques
aménagements bonne donne un coup de
frein londres s'interroge
bref l'europe des privatisations chancel
entre guillemets en quête de nos
correspondants pourtant ce mois dernier
l'anc et fixé officiellement à londres
le prix de l'action de bp
on vend 31% du capital tout le monde
pense que ce sera un succès et c'est la
tempête monétaire
le cours de bp chute de 25% avant même
la vente au public les institutions
financières chargé de la privatisation
ont déjà acheté toutes les actions
au prix fort les financiers de la city
panique
coup de poker du chancelier de
l'échiquier on privatise quand même mais
la banque d'angleterre pourra racheter
les titres fils tombe trop bas ce qui
correspond à une renationalisation
partielle le coup réussi
les actions de bp qu'on attendait en
chute libre remonte la city est rassuré
mais les petits porteurs ne sont pas au
rendez vous échec du capitalisme
populaire chez volkswagen l'état détient
20% des actions soit près de 4 milliards
de francs alors qu'avant la crise de la
bourse il en possédait pour 6 milliards
le ministère allemand des finances
comptait bien sur cette somme pour
boucler son budget 87 en déficit de 30
milliards de francs c'est un coup sévère
pour le gouvernement conservateur qui
reste pourtant décidé à poursuivre sa
politique de privatisation quand le
marché des capitaux le permettra l'état
veut en effet se dégager des
participations dans l'industrie nez du
régime hitlérien le report de la
privatisation de volkswagen intervient
au moment même où la gente chance
responsable du scandale financier qui a
frappé la firme vient d'être arrêté à
los angeles et précisément à cause de ce
scandale
la privatisation avait déjà été reporté
en france c'est aussi la pause
matra privatisation prévue pour le 26
octobre repoussé sans qu'une nouvelle
date était fixée suez première cotation
reporté au 9 novembre avec un risque
important que ce us soit la première
société à être cotée au dessous de son
cours devant 317 prend car sur le marché
les londoniens l'action s'échange à 290
francs
hu a fait le gros morceau plus de 25
milliards de francs privatisations
prévues au départ en décembre devrait
quand même se faire le gouvernement et
tient beaucoup pour les autres sociétés
dont la privatisation était envisagée
avant les présidentielles les ag est une
société industrielle banques de dépôt
cela paraît très compromis à paris
changement de décor la chambre
criminelle de la cour de cassation
examiné cet après-midi la requête en
suspicion légitime présenté par michel
droit à l'encontre de juges grelier
je rappelle que le juge grelier et
chargé de l'instruction du dossier de la
cncl et qu'à ce titre il avait inculpé
voici quelques jours michel droit de
forfaiture on vient d'apprendre que la
cour de cassation avait ordonné la
suspension de
l'instruction du dossier de la cncl la
cour se prononcera sur le fond de la
sphère le 10 décembre prochain
explications de pascal deschamps le juge
grelier semble ce soir avoir perdu la
partie bras de fer qui l'opposait depuis
près de deux semaines à mettre varaut
l'avocat de michel droit en effet au
lendemain de l'inculpation
d'académiciens le 27 octobre
l'avocat avait lancé ces attaques tous
azimuts contre le magistrat réclamant à
la fois le non-lieu pour un dossier vide
et le dessaisissement du juge sans
oublier une plainte pour violation du
secret de l'instruction
la décision d'aujourd'hui suspension
provisoire de l'instruction apparaît
comme un dessaisissement d'urgence à un
mois de la décision définitive cette
demande 2 et saisissement est détestable
à l'égard dû magistrat à l'égard du
système judiciaire et les têtes esta
mais je n'avais pas de solution car il
était évident qu'il n'y avait rien dans
le dossier au moment de l'inculpation il
n'y avait rien à vendredi après
l'audition de michel droit mais
apparemment rien ne laissait espérer
dans un temps très rapides et très
nécessaire à l'onu pour les avocats de
la partie civile
l'afer est d'ores et déjà enterré une
défaite pour la démocratie mais sans
doute une victoire pour monsieur le juge
grellier
car le déclenchement de l'artillerie
lourde pour monsieur droit académiciens
au dessus des lois
une suspension immédiate des
investigations de monsieur grille et je
pose une question que veut tu ont gâché
par ce dessaisissement à grande vitesse
du magistrat instructeur
je n'aimerais pas être à la place du
successeur de monsieur le juge collier
le procureur général pierre arpaillange
se serait opposé cet après midi à la
suspension une décision qui selon lui
porterait atteinte à l'indépendance des
juges et déstabiliserait l'institution
judiciaire tout entière voilà c'est tout
ce que l'on peut dire ce soir à paris la
cfdt de l'agroalimentaire n'est pas
contente et elle a fait savoir cet après
midi au ministre de l'agriculture en
déposant devant son ministère vous le
voyez plusieurs centaines de pots de
chrysanthèmes et oui les manifestants
déplorent le manque de dialogue avec les
pouvoirs publics
et annonce des pertes d'emplois
considérable depuis 1983
ils ont demandé au ministre françois
guillaume une concertation sur le projet
de modernisation de l'agriculture
avant la discussion au parlement une
bonne nouvelle à la veille du sommet de
l' agence spatiale européenne qui se
tiendra à vous le savez à l'oeil lundi
et mardi prochain les allemands ont
décidé de soutenir ariane 5
que voici dont le premier vol est prévu
pour 1995 en revanche il souhaiterait
que le lancement d'hermès le voilà soit
retardé de trois ans ce qui est moins
bon mais les spécialistes font remarquer
que c'est mieux que l'abandon pur et
simple du projet au palais bourbon le
budget de l'audiovisuel public qui a été
défendue tout à l'heure par françois
léotard qui ce soir notre invité un
budget très discuté nous y reviendrons
dans quelques instants avant cela le
constat et les chiffres globalement il y
as 350 millions de recettes
supplémentaires voyons salle en détail
première constatation le budget de
l'audiovisuel public dans lequel pour la
première fois tf1 ne figure pas se
caractérise cette année par une grande
stabilité
les tarifs de la redevance sont
maintenus à 333 francs pour un pote noir
et blanc 506 francs pour un récepteur
couleurs et les ressources publicitaires
restent plafonnés à 2 milliards de
francs pourtant grâce à la progression
du parc de téléviseurs et à un meilleur
recouvrement de la redevance certains
budgets sont en hausse
premier bénéficiaire antenne 2 qui avec
2 milliards 900 millions de francs voit
ses recettes augmenter de 15 % des
sommes qu'ils iront principalement à la
création audiovisuelle et à
l'information augmentation aussi pour
fr3 et pour rfo radio france outre-mer
qui devra étendre son réseau dans les
départements et les territoires éloignés
budget stable pour radio france lina rfi
mais fonds publics en baisse en revanche
pour tdf télédiffusion de france dont
les recettes devront venir l'année
prochaine en grande partie des chaînes
privées
un budget de l'audiovisuel public qui
entraîne une baisse des effectifs 202
personnes ne seront pas remplacés en 88
est aujourd'hui une grève générale d'une
journée a eu lieu à france inter
fr3 et rfi premières questions très
pratiques monsieur le ministre avec un
budget comme celui là est ce qu'une
chaîne comme la nôtre antenne 2 va
pouvoir lutter à armes égales contre sa
grande concurrente tf1 sur vous
avait entendu les chiffres ils sont
exacts pour cette partie là 15%
d'augmentation pour antenne 2 c'est un
chiffre tout à fait considérable pour le
budget 88 donc la réponse est oui
des deux pourra affronter la concurrence
du secteur privé je peux vous le dire qu
elle le fait déjà pour ce qui concerne
l'information ou d'autres secteurs a
fait que beaucoup de talent alors il ya
un petit plus mais si j'ai bien compris
on va devoir lever le pied sur la
publicité est ce que c'est peut-être un
peu caricatural vous n'êtes pas en train
de nous enlever d'une main ce que vous
nous avez donné de l'autre n'ont la
décision de plafonner les ressources
publicitaires elle a été prise déjà pour
deux ans pour qu'elle s'applique encore
en 88
mais ce sont quand même des ressources
importantes ce que nous voulons c'est
que les ressources du secteur public
soit la redevance et la publicité et
bien sûr pour la publicité encadré c'est
tout à fait normal puisqu'il s'agit de
deux chaînes du secteur public je pense
qu'avec ça vous avez entendu les
chiffres ce sont des budgets tout à fait
considérable près de 3 milliards de
francs pour antenne 2 c'est tout à fait
important et une augmentation de 15%
ça vous donne les moyens et vous le
faites d'ailleurs pour ce qui concerne
la création française d'ailleurs
d'affronter tout à fait les défis qui
vous sont lancés on revient en quelques
mots en quelques minutes au débat de cet
après-midi les bas difficile pour vous
au palais bourbon vous avez été attaqué
de plein fouet notamment ce qui est tout
à fait normal par certains députés de
l'opposition notamment du parti
socialiste on écoute tout de suite
jean-jack queyranne chaîne de service
public comme on n 2 de lutter à armes
égales avec les chaînes privées l'année
prochaine en tender à 500 millions de
moins de recettes que tf1 la concurrence
ne pourra pas se produire
ce budget au fond il est un peu à
l'image la cheville de monsieur léotard
l'audiovisuel boîte et je crains que
monsieur léotard se rétablit sont
beaucoup plus vite que les chaînes de
télévision pour gagner le marathon de
l'audiovisuel aujourd'hui il faut
renforcer les moyens audiovisuels pour
faire face à la concurrence et je crois
qu'ils étaient les spectateurs
sont très mécontents de ce qui se passe
à la télévision trop de programmes
étrangers trop de séries américaines
pas assez de films et de séries
conscience monsieur queyranne a
incontestablement le sens de la formule
je vous laisse répondre influer nous il
est gentil pour ma cheville c'est gentil
la réalité est la suivante c'est que je
comprends les socialistes soient pas
très content parce qu'ils perdent le
contrôle en fait de l'audiovisuel et
c'est vrai que ça a toujours été une
démarche et de très fortes
la vérité c'est que nous avons voulu
engager un processus de liberté et de
concurrence et ce processus de liberté
des figures ans il se traduit
aujourd'hui par un secteur privé que
tout le monde connaît qui marche bien et
un secteur public est le vôtre avec fr3
avec d'autres sociétés et qui marchent
également très bien je voudrais rappeler
que on aura fait en création ce qui est
un vrai problème évoqué par monsieur k
d'ailleurs à juste titre en création
française on leur a fait en deux ans
plus que dans les cinq années
précédentes en volume d'argent dépensé
simplement il faut le temps entre le
moment où un scénario est déposée devant
antenne 2 par exemple le moment où
antenne de programmes ce scénario comme
une émission il faut entre 18 mois et
deux ans alors il faut on peut bien sûr
laisser le temps est ce que cet argent
puisse se produire ses effets trois
dernières questions françois léotard
certains syndicats de l'audiovisuel
étaient en grève aujourd'hui olivier
dernière le disais tout à l'heure ils
craignent visiblement des licenciements
est-ce que vous pouvez les rassurer ce
qu'il n'y aura pas de licenciements en
je suis tellement j'ai entendu ça leur
grève générale je crois que les chiffres
on verra ça ce soir ou demain matin ses
deux autres 12 et 15% il faut quand même
que certains syndicats donnent 60 % on
verra demain mais dont ce que je voulais
dire simplement c'est que les troubles
sociaux ou les conflits sociaux dans
l'audiovisuel depuis 18 mois nous ont
été infiniment inférieurs à tous qui
l'ont été dans des périodes comparables
auparavant donc le calme prévaut et la
raison prévost la deuxième chose que je
tiens à dire devant vous c'est qu'il ya
pas de licenciements prévus et il n'est
pas question de licenciements 1988 dans
l'audiovisuel
simplement ce qui est nécessaire
on le dit pour chacune des sociétés
c'est un effort de productivité vous le
faites radio france le fait un certain
nombre de sociétés le font et c'est très
bien alors on oublie quelques instants
l'audiovisuel moi j'aimerais savoir ce
que vous pensez du sondage du nouvel obs
à propos des affaires dont on parle
beaucoup vous l'avez encore entendu tout
à l'heure la classe politique s'en sort
mal monsieur le ministre 56% des
personnes interrogées pensent que les
politiques sont avant tout soucieux de
leurs intérêts personnels
c'est ce qu'on en pense et je comprends
que les français quand il regarde un peu
les informations ils sont un petit peu
et pleurer parce qu'ils se disent qu'est
ce que ça veut dire qu'est-ce qui est ce
que ces gens là on est à dire et est ce
qu'il cache des choses je crois qu'il
faut retrouver quelques principes
simples d'abord la justice il faut faire
confiance à la justice c'est la justice
qui doit trancher tous les différentes
nous pouvons avoir
et surtout les choses frauduleuse que
peuvent faire telle ou telle personne
quel que soit son statut
deuxièmement c'est la démocratie les
hommes politiques sont comme les
français et ils sont jugés par ceux qui
les élisent et donc à des élections il
faut que les français y participent et
qui disent je veux qu'on aille dans
telle direction plutôt que dans telle
autre la démocratie ça n'est pas quelque
chose de malsain et enfin troisièmement
je crois qu'il faut que effectivement
les hommes politiques disent davantage
la vérité c'est plus difficile je
reconnais mais il faut qu'ils s'y
efforce parce que sinon ils seront plus
du tout écouter et que les gens se
retireront même du débat politique
une dernière question au secrétaire
général du parti républicain pourquoi
avoir retiré le dossier des élections à
michel d'ornano est tout simplement
parce que c'est une responsabilité du
secrétaire général je répondrai que j'ai
tout à l'heure sur la vérité leucate
honda une formation politique d'une
famille politique doit prendre ça
directement en charge sinon il à quoi il
sert la réponse très simple et très
franche merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
la politique encore et me l'hémorragie
continue au parti communiste après le
départ spectaculaire de marcel rigou et
de la majorité des dirigeants du pc de
la haute vienne
c'est dans le finistère en bretagne que
la crise s'amplifie on appris
aujourd'hui le départ de huit militants
du pc parmi lesquels deux adjoints au
maire de concarneau l'étranger au
nicaragua le président daniel ortega
prône la décrispation devant cent mille
sympathisants et hier à managua
le président a déclaré qu'il était
favorable à l'ouverture de négociations
indirectes avec les chefs de la
résistance déclaration importante car
jusqu'à présent il avait toujours refusé
une telle éventualité
explications de bernard benyamin
hier après midi place de la révolution à
managua
on attendait un rejet implicite du plan
de paix arias c'est une négociation avec
la contra indirects il est vrai qu
annonce daniel ortega la surprise et
elle est de taille constitue en fait la
dernière concession des autorités
sandiniste pour la paix en amérique
centrale
il y a quelques semaines en effet la
prensa le seul journal d'opposition
avaient été autorisés à reparaître après
plus d'un an d'interruption
puis ce fut au tour de radio catholique
a elle aussi fermé en raison de ses
critiques répétées à l'égard du
gouvernement
au même moment une commission de
réconciliation nationale été créés dont
la présidence a été confiée à l'un des
plus grands adversaires du régime
le cardinal au bandeau libre à vous
enfin dernier geste de bonne volonté
depuis un mois des milliers et des
milliers de nicaraguayens peuvent se
précipiter à la frontière hondurienne de
las manos l'instant d'un après midi il y
rencontre un parent ou un ami qui ont
fui le régime de managua et qui vivent
aujourd'hui réfugié honduras la première
conséquence de cette décision
elle est d'ordre politique et militaire
c'est l'embarras qu'elle va provoquer à
washington il faut s'attendre du reste
un ajournement du plan des dallas
contrat que le président reagan doit
présenter au congrès reste à savoir
enfin ce qui a bien pu provoquer cette
volte face certains déjà veulent qu y
voir un effet de la glace noces en
amérique centrale
daniel ortega a annoncé sa décision
sitôt rentré d'un voyage à moscou
elles ont rapidement les autres
télégramme de l'étranger le commentaire
est signé rémy roche move and me qui a
retrouvé sa force sa faim à port
elizabeth après 23 ans de détention à 77
ans l'ancien président de l' insee qui
avait été condamné à la prison à vie se
dit frère poursuivre son combat
nationaliste sans pour autant occuper de
responsabilités
par ailleurs trois noir condamné à mort
on s'était pendu aujourd'hui à pretoria
l'un d'entre eux était militant
antiapartheid mais les autorités
sud-africaines assure que les trois
hommes étaient des criminels de droit
commun
reprise des hostilités dans le golfe à
48 heures de l'ouverture du sommet arabe
dahmane un pétrolier américain battant
pavillon panaméen a été attaqué à la
roquette par une vedette iranienne
le navire a pu rejoindre le port de
dubaï téhéran et bagdad annoncent pour
leur part plusieurs bombardements de
cibles ennemies par leur aviation
un nouveau premier ministre pour le
japon noburu takeshita qui succède à
monsieur n'a qu'a sonné démissionnaire a
été élue à une large majorité du
parlement
63 ans président du parti libéral
démocrate au pouvoir que chez takeshita
promet de poursuivre la politique
d'alliance étroite avec les états unis
et les résultats économiques qui est pas
dû réduire leurs excédents commerciaux
le canada en deuil pour les obsèques de
rené lévesque beaucoup d'émotion et de
recueillement est fait sans précédent
dans l'histoire du canada les drapeaux
ont été mis en berne dans tout le pays
en mémoire un homme qui avoue et tous
ses efforts à l'indépendance du québec
patrick boies émotions recueillement
pour des milliers de québécois rendant
un dernier hommage à rené comme on le
nomme ici ce n'était pas seulement un
homme politique mais un communicateur
selon lui qu'est ce que ça représentait
pour vous rené lévesque
venez les vagues ont eu en main c'est le
je crois que non seulement elle pas la
révolution tranquille c'est aussi le
père des patriotes pas d'épée triade
aujourd'hui je pense qu'un héritage
comme ça ne peut jamais se faire hacker
croll le reprend d'armé et il comptera
pour faire si la lutte de cet homme mort
à 65 ans qui a été unanimement saluée
par le monde politique francophone
la population est voué une grande
admiration même si parfois et lui manqua
de fidélité le lien entre eux n'étaient
pas seulement un pays mais une langue le
français libres sur ma rejoignent les
gars l'histoire d'un gars entier
campagne maintenant disparu ça risque
d'être the way est encore plus fort pour
le français en amérique également car
c'est vrai que c'est lui qui a dit à
l'amérique y avait un peuple français au
québec
et c'était nous c'est ça la grosse perte
sa disparition inquiète désormais les
jeunes pour l'avenir
le canada tout entier a été très émue
par le départ un peu trop rapide de rené
le québécois le sport jean ma mère on
craignait pour yannick noah cet après
midi à bercy ben on n'avait pas tort et
oui les premiers signes avant coureurs
s'étaient manifestés hier soir dans le
match contre le mans / bahrami en
huitièmes de finale
aujourd'hui noah souffrais beaucoup trop
il a dû déclarer forfait avant
d'affronter schepers à l'entraînement
cet après midi et nous allons le voir
sur ces images un entraînement auquel
assistent et patrick chêne noah ne
semblait pas au mieux et surtout il
souffrait déjà de la boum n en plus ces
propos dès les premières balles ne
cachait pas son souci
après quelques balles et avoir beaucoup
souffert yannick noah a craqué voulait
affronter chez pearson joueur à sa
portée même handicapé mais sur le
conseil de ses médecins et afin de ne
pas aggraver la mission elle a préféré
relancer nous a semblé bien remis après
sa victoire à bâle mais décidément il
sort à nouveau par la petite porte alors
exit yannick noah existe heureusement il
reste
henri leconte qui joue en ce moment on
va se tourner vers berlin en direct en
ce moment nous sommes dans le troisième
set c'est le troisième jeu les deux
hommes sont à égalité un jeu partout
cash est au service et une semaine pour
l'instant 40 francs henri leconte à je
dirais un peu raté le coche puisqu'il a
il a eu trois balles de match pour lui
dans le deuxième set mais il a été battu
aux tie break par pas de cacher là où
l'on reconnaît les grands en difficulté
ils savent toujours être là mais henri
leconte vous offre un très beau
spectacle ainsi que pat cash selon eux
très vite les pronostics de pirey de
brest pour le tiercé de demain à saint
cloud 15 partants voici ses pronostics
vous allez voir apparaître sur le petit
écran tout moi je l'espère le 9
malaspina pas facile à dire le 4 toben
wad le 6 on les a pas le ciss sympa
somme pour - le 6 grego laisse le un
fard à joue là le 8 super aran 1 le 2 a
lieu le 13 silver armada et le 12 sucre
look que ça fait donc le 9 le 4 le 6 le
1 le 8 tonnes voici le 2 le 13 et le 12
j'espère que vous avez noté ça peut
rapporter gros seins pirette donne très
souvent le tiercé et le kart est allé
sans transition on embraye avec la météo
on est toujours dans le brouillard
laurent si j'ai bien compris que vous
lui effectivement et la paresse du vent
et la cause des brouillards tardif qui
s'en vont doucement un peu comme en
rêvant nous avons eu aujourd'hui du
brouillard très tardifs à la région
parisienne au point que les températures
n'ont pas excéder 5 degrés à paris
demain nous commençons à changer de
régime
nous allons maintenant arrivés avec des
températures un peu plus douce dans le
courant de la journée de dimanche et sur
la photo satellite vous voyez arriver
une perturbation cette perturbation ne
va pas encore effleuré nos côtes mais
elle ne sera pas très loin c'est
pourquoi nous allons la laisser là
encore pour la journée de demain
mais dimanche il viendra nous rencontrer
la journée de demain la voici maintenant
sur la couleur du temps que nous vous
proposons avec encore et bien des nuages
qui seront
disons des nuages bas qui seront
présents tout au long de la journée sur
la moitié nord de la france
alors qu'au sud de soleil dominera les
températures pendant que je vous
observez les températures maximales je
vous donne les geler en champagne
lorraine alsace bourgogne dans la vallée
de la seine et la vallée de la saône
il y aura des gelées demain matin pensez
aux plantes et enfin il fera 10 degrés
dans le nord à eyrein à eyrein le bas
couvrez-vous le bas des reins jusque
demain matin il fera encore très froid
dans ces régions alors que nous
souhaiterons la saccharine et que le
soleil se lèvera 7h48 pour se coucher à
17h20 merci bon week-end le rang avant
de vous quitter je vous signale quand n
2 est à l'honneur notre confrère daniel
leconte a reçu aujourd'hui le prion d'as
pour un reportage diffusé en mai 87 sur
notre antenne bien sûr reportage
intitulé la deuxième vie de klaus barbie
prochain rendez vous d'information 23
heures avec au brier de l'air pendant le
week-end vous retrouverez comme
d'habitude daniel bilalian et philippe
gassot demain à 13h15 n'oubliez pas
l'assiette anglaise présenté par bernard
rapp excellent week-end on se retrouve
lundi 20h bonsoir